now i'm going to take you to moscow
we're going to listen to sergey lavrov
russian foreign minister
it
has done this all these years and this
unites uh
theoretical and political experience and
this is uh also the way to understand
the most important foreign processes
especially at times like now the council
now
and the
analytical discussions and materials
sometimes very sharp discussions and all
this helps us and we take them into
account in our foreign political
activities it's a common place to say
that
this is a
break through time and i agree with the
experts and sergey alexander
and uh
wrote about this and when they say that
today is in
17th and 90 1991 that we face
a choice in our politics and the foreign
situation has changed radically and they
change every day and deeper and deeper
and broader and broader
and we can't jump
higher but we feel that it's deepening
and our country is changing together
with these circumstances and it makes
its uh
conclusions the choice we're making now
it has already been made
and it's that the collective west has
announced a total hybrid war on us it's
difficult to forecast how long this all
will last but it's clear that the
consequences will be felt by everybody
without exception we've done everything
to avoid a direct clash but the
challenge has been uh thrown to us so we
accepted the it's uh when nothing new to
sanctions we've always been under
sanctions
what surprises is uh the cavemen's uh
russophobia explosion which we witnessed
in all the civilized so-called civilized
countries the political correctness so
any distance
any rules and also legal norms have been
thrown away
the
cancer culture against everything
russian is being implemented and all
hostile actions against our country
including theft
our cultural activists sportsmen
scientists businessmen just russians are
being robbed this company hasn't spared
our diplomats
they often have to work in extreme
circumstances and sometimes with risk to
life and health even in the darkest
times of the cold war
didn't see such a synchronous
expulsion of diplomats we don't remember
that of course this destroys the general
atmosphere in relations with the west
but at the same time it releases and
frees
forces and resources human resources to
work
in the areas
which
can be
used to develop the future of our
country
we have conscientiously conducted our
professional responsibilities fully
they couldn't find the traitors among
diplomats there were such attempts
abroad and inside the country we are
doing everything we can to defend the
rights and interests of our citizens
abroad
when a historical reaction from the west
began
at the beginning of the special military
operation when all
aviation
flights were cancelled we provided help
to our citizens
who were abroad we helped them
to return home and of course the current
issues are still valid especially to do
with the consular services
to russians of course the situation made
it
necessary to
transfer our
diplomatic services to an extreme
mode of operation and especially
in the area of defending our national
interests of course everything doesn't
just concern ukraine ukraine is an
instrument a tool to contain russia's
peaceful development and
this is
also promoted
one polar
world the americans started to
plan this course since this end of the
cold war to establish the the global
hegemony and
the expansion to the east was part of
this course we
tried to convince them for a long time
why this was not good we
were flexible and we were ready to
meet them halfway and to look for
compromise that was all in vain and our
president uh reminding this uh in his
speech
on the 9th of may on red square and
now
the west is opposing russian to the last
ukrainian especially the united states
which is conducting these processes
from beyond the ocean and they're also
weakening europe
and
release
emptying the preparing the market for
their own goods and services and of
course the situation is
has several layers
russia the united states and china we
all understand that
the
issue is at stake whether the world will
be
just
democratic and multi-polar so this is a
small whether this small group of
countries will be able to impose the
colonial division of the world to the
uh those who can and those who cannot
and we have already spoken about this
this
concept of the so-called
rule rule-based
order
has been implemented for many years
nobody
approved this order but it's being
imposed on the world community and i
will quote
the u.s
finance minister
she said recently and i quote the
creation of a new
system has to be
starts with the definition of the values
of liberal democracy the united states
would support
supply chains
involving only those countries which
respects moral values and behavior norms
end of quotes of course you understand
what this means
this is all to do with the dollar and
and only those
should be
admitted to this dollar system if they
agree with these american rules and
those who don't will be punished not
just a rush but everybody who can uh
pursue independent policies will be
under attack just look at the pacific uh
strategy promoted by washington and
which has uh
which pursues the aim to include india
and reliably and firmly into the
american and nato
fault
as for the monroe doctrine the united
states dictates the latin america how to
live but the question is can the
americans
now pursue on in
reality that the doctrine that the
united nations are based on equality of
nations the rule-based order doesn't
include plurality and other principles
but it's all to do with uh
the obedience to washington's dictate
and they don't take prisoners the
european union loses its principles of
independence and it just joins the
anglo-saxon plans to promote this one
polar world order and it risks the
quality of life of the europeans and
their
native interests to please the united
states just remember how in december
2013 victoria noland during
in a conversation with the u.s
ambassador in kiev during the maidan
events when she
defined the main
the place of the eu in the in
washington's plans to reformat ukraine
and this prediction has uh come true
fully at the same time the eu in
security issues has gradually
been merging with nato it
subjugates to nato and nato announces
its global ambitions what kind of
defense
alliance is that
when they say that uh the nato's
expansion is a defense process but that
it doesn't threaten anybody if you
listen to stole stoltenberg or
the american zone the the brits this the
line of defense that was that went
through
the berlin wall the the real and the
imaginatory ones between the two blocks
it has already moved twice to the east
and they say now stoltenberg is too uh
through the
mouths of liz truss and others that
nato has a global responsibility for
solving security issues and first of all
in the
in
the pacific region so the line of
defense they want to move it to the area
of the southern chinese sea
so the uh idea that uh that nato as an
uh one vanguard of world democracy uh
should uh include this policy and the
dominant governance of global economy
should be
covered by g7 which will be
which will invite some obedient nations
from time to time of course the western
politicians should understand that their
effect
efforts to isolate our countries are in
vain many experts
understand this now and they recognize
it now and not
publicly but behind the scenes
this happens and outside the western
there's an understanding that the world
becomes more diverse you can't avoid
this and the more and more countries try
to achieve a real
freedom they take part in integration
processes and projects and more and more
asian and latin american countries are
not prepared to
risk their
national interests to please
international monopolies and many of our
partners who
felt
the west colonial
habits they don't join these sanctions
the west
which in our president's
statement became an empire of lies
is not perceived
now as a
world of
ideals they steal other people's assets
they have
lost their reputation as reliable
partners nobody is
safe from
expropriation and
state
piracy and not just russia but other
countries don't want to be depend on the
us
dollar and uh
technologies and i think that uh in
future uh this the the world economy
will be the americanized uh as mr uh
luchanov wrote in the newspaper camera
center recently that
the
west
has stopped listening to us this
happened before long before the start of
the
special military operation and his
article also says that
the radical reorientation of assets from
the west
is quite unnecessary i remember that
this philosophy this course
was promoted by sergey karaganov for
many years and
many now clearly understand this
process has started and it wasn't our
desire we always we were always
open to dialogue but this happened
through our western partners
behavior which acted
and which
canceled russia from their
partnership so
so
this is uh
an unavoidable process and it's a mutual
process russian chinese relations
become deeper and deeper is
privileged
partnership with indian strategic
partnership with algae and egypt
relations with the gulf countries are
becoming reaching new levels the same
with the association of countries of the
southeast asia and other countries in
the pacific
region in the middle east asia africa
latin america
we understand that
at this
watershed period
this is
an adjective
once i want to use this it's it's
this moment defines russia's
place in the future world order we see
russia diplomacy's
task as to
reflect
hostile actions against us but also to
patiently and calmly but
faster work on defending our positions
to promote our country's development and
improve our citizens quality of life
does
there is a lot to do
it never
we're always busy but in this situation
of course
the we're seriously changing the
mentality of our
comrades in all the areas of russia's
life and especially
at such stages and its
meetings are very important
under the
umbrella of the council for
foreign and defense
policy which has been generating ideas
for a long time which feeds also our
foreign policies in
uh
i think uh representatives of the audio
visual information means
as always
that was the russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov effectively painting the
position of russia as a victim of
western aggression says the west has
declared a hybrid
war against us and that efforts to
isolate russia
will be in vain as warned about
he was warning as well about
over-expansion
via nato in the east of course very
pertinent given that we have just learnt
that the finnish prime minister has had
a telephone call with president putin
today
to tell him that they will be applying
in the next few days to accede
to nato he talked a lot about the
hegemony of the united states and saying
that they had imposed a rule-based order
on the world without any other kind of
agreement and talked about the hostile
environment for russians
abroad
all of that there by
sergey lavrov the russian foreign
minister speaking a few moments ago in
moscow